good morning John I just find myself in
this situation of having so much good
news I don't really know what to do
about it I don't even really know where
to begin usually the beginning so I
guess this week you made a video about
how there's a drug for multi-drug
resistant tuberculosis called
bedaqueline it's been around for 20
years its patent is expiring and it
looked like Johnson and Johnson the
owner of that drug was going to figure
out a way to extend that patent for
another four years during which time a
lot of people wouldn't have access to
and you were mad about that and you're
not the only person mad about that but
you were the only person with a fairly
large internet audience who'd spent the
last year establishing themselves as a
person who's very passionate about
tuberculosis who knew about it and I
have to be honest with you John there
were times in the last year when I'm
like maybe this guy is a little bit over
investing in his dedication to
tuberculosis a sensation I no longer
have because of course as you get deeper
and deeper and deeper into something you
start to see that there are people
working really hard on Solutions and
that those Solutions really do exist and
that there are things that we can do now
that will make the world better so you
made this video and then Nerdfighters
went nuts on Reddit and on Twitter and
on other social media platforms that I
don't use as often probably there were
letters there were phone calls I hope
that everyone was polite and then
Johnson and Johnson put out this
statement
classic first line it is false to
suggest as some recently have that our
patents are being used to prevent access
to serguro but equally in our medicine
for multi-drug resistant TV it is false
to suggest as some recently have that I
misplaced my normal lens for
vlogbrothers and that's why this video
looks a little weird because I'm
shooting another 50 millimeter
you're very
very and look here's one
thing Johnson who have worked way harder
on multi-drug resistant TB than I ever
have in my life and so I don't want to
be mad at the entire institution of
Johnson and Johnson people who work on
infectious disease research do that when
they could be working on stuff that
probably would make them a lot more
money like cures for baldness or cancer
research which is very profitable and so
like writing off an entire company is
the wrong thing to do but this statement
was bad and it was misleading and I
didn't like it and then this morning as
I'm recording this so yesterday morning
and this happened in a week John you
made a video on Tuesday it's Friday
right now stop TV partnership released a
statement that said following lengthy
negotiations Johnson and Johnson has
granted stop PB Partnerships Global Drug
facility a license that enabled gdf to
Tender procure and Supply generic
versions of bedaquiline for the majority
of low and middle income countries
including countries where patents remain
in effect so they aren't canceling the
patent but they're allowing generics to
be used in places with a high burden of
TB everybody agrees that there should be
less tuberculosis in the world now we
don't all agree on how exactly they get
there or what the right things to do are
but John you got into the rooms where
the people are right now talking about
how to deal with drug resistant
tuberculosis and you found out that
there was a barrier that didn't need to
be there and we then as a community
asked whether or not that barrier could
be eliminated and in the course of a few
days it was that's very weird and it's
not something that can happen every day
it's not something that I don't think
we'll ever achieve anything of that
magnitude again it was a particular
circumstance that was only possible to
take on because you have been focusing
on one of the world's greatest problems
that a lot of people don't focus on or
think about very much for a year more
than a year now you've been a little
hyper obsessed but in the right thing
I'm really proud to be a part of this
community I'm really proud to be your
brother and I'm really proud of all the
amazing memes that I saw over the last
few days both the ones that were
critical and the ones that were
celebrating the actions that Johnson and
Johnson has taken to make sure that we
can live in a world with lest he be as
fast as possible maybe someday a world
with no tuberculosis so that's the first
piece of good news and that's enough for
like one of the best vlogbrothers videos
of all time uh but I have more good news
so completely shifting gears I feel like
this should be a whole other video but
completely shifting gears since I only
do one a week I don't want to like not
say the situation with my lymphoma is
that we started out it looked pretty
good it's Hodgkin's lymphoma it's a
treatable disease
um and in the majority of cases it
responded well to treatment minded and
so I have had my last chemo of my
treatment plan so I only had to do four
sessions of chemotherapy the result I'm
actually going to show you pictures of
scans now if you don't want to see those
you can close you can just listen to my
voice so here's me before so obviously
the and the dark is areas of high
glucose uptake in a pet scan cancer
cells use a lot of glucose and they use
it bizarrely so they use it way more
than normal tissue and so that looks
very dark those are my lymph nodes super
swollen with cancer cells and then here
is now which looks like nothing now it's
not nothing if you look at some of the
more high resolution pet scans that the
doctors look at there's a little bit of
glucose uptake in in two of my lymph
nodes still not all of them most of them
have shrunk back to normal size two of
them are still swollen this is very
common it's normal and this is exactly
what they want to see at this point in
treatment now we do radiation because
the idea is there's probably some cancer
cells still in there which my immune
system might take care of on its own but
it might not and so you do radiation so
in a couple of weeks I'm going to start
radiation I have a meeting with my
doctor next week to sort of plan that
out after that like unless something
goes very weird I will be in remission
and then we will monitor me for a long
time years to make sure that it isn't
coming back and if it happens then
they've got things that they can do to
take it on now those things suck they're
like worse than what I've been through
so far but there are still things I can
do even if the worst case scenario I
relapse and have lymphoma again but for
now clearly my particular cancer is
responsive to the chemotherapy I have
killed and pissed out so many cancer
cells and I will not tell you the chemo
is fun it's so not fun it is the least
fun thing I've ever done in my life I I
hate it but it is also amazing it is so
powerful and I feel so lucky to live in
a world where I get to have access to
this where the hospital is not far away
from my house where there have been
Decades of people working to refine
these treatment plans so you can get the
best result with the cancer with the
least potential long-term side effects
which is also something that I will
continue to have to monitor for because
there are chemo drugs I was on can give
you other diseases that on campus oh
it's always a trade-off every medication
is a trade-off for the side effects but
with chemotherapy there's a particular
understanding of the need to maintain a
balance between the long-term side
effects of the treatment and the
long-term side effects of the disease in
short it's very good news and barring
something very weird I will officially
be in remission in maybe two months so
that's where we're at with everything
it's the best news video of all 15 plus
years of vlogbrother what a moment
um I'm feeling good and also I'm just so
grateful that I don't have to get chemo
today today would be the day when I
would be getting chemo if I was still on
chemo and I would absolutely do it but I
don't have to which is exciting because
I didn't like it
John I'll see you on Tuesday